okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i'm happy to try and answer
questions about
all kinds of topics about science and
technology
both things you think are elementary and
things you might think are complicated
and advanced i'll see what i can do and
try and explain them as best i can
let me see we have a number of questions
that got saved up from previous
times oh here's an interesting one from
hamid
what is the physical limitation of the
growth speed of humans can you get from
10 kilometers to 90 kilometers in a
month theoretically
okay that's an interesting question
so
you know one
there's there's a whole issue of how
things grow what actually is happening
the fundamental way that ultimately
organisms grow is by making new cells by
having one cell divide into two and in
in the case of us humans we've divided
well our cells divide up to about 50
times
and so we we keep on doubling the number
of cells
although it's more controlled than that
when we build different you know parts
of ourselves so to speak but
fundamentally what you have to do to
grow
is to uh create new cells
and
in terms of you know when people put on
weight and so on it's not all just uh
creating new cells it can also be kind
of having more water retained in
existing cells and things like that
but if you really want to grow you have
to make new cells
so one question is how quickly can you
do that what's involved in making a new
cell
well you have to start off with the dna
which is the specification of of what
proteins should exist in a cell and so
on uh for us humans dna is six billion
base pairs long
and uh separated into 23 chromosomes and
what happens when if you want to make a
copy of a cell the first thing you've
got to do is to copy that genetic
information and that process
the the as the way that works is the dna
which is has two strands in it the
strands pull apart and gradually one
strand will refill with a complementary
other strand and that takes a certain
amount of time to happen
then
other things have to happen in the cells
you have to copy the dna
then the various different other pieces
of the cell have to also get replicated
like our mitochondria that produce
energy originally started as quite
separate organisms but they've been uh
sort of living inside us for the last
few billion years
and they have to they they they um have
their own um uh
replication and then the actual surface
of the cell
has to uh kind of
uh has to
split apart and uh create a new cell so
for different kinds of organisms and
that depends a bit on the length of the
dna it can take different amounts of
time for cells to replicate i don't
actually know what the time for cell
replication is for humans i'm guessing
it's on the order of
six hours to a day something like that
for some bacteria and other simpler
cells it can be a matter of of 10
minutes or something like this
but i think for us humans the time for
the actual process of replicating cells
um there's a certain limit to how
quickly you can grow just on on the
basis of replicating cells
now
there's also the question of well if we
grow
which part we have to grow in the right
proportions i mean it can't be the case
that i mean there's some very early
organisms back
in i don't know the um
uh
the pre-cambrian period
um you know from these stromatolites for
example which are some early organisms
that you find distributed and you know
you find fossils of and i think they had
the feature that they just they just
grow and they make sort of blobs and
they keep on growing and they don't
really have any kind of structure or
control of oh i want to grow something
where i have an arm and it's a certain
length and things like this
we we have much more detailed control of
growth i mean it's the thing to remember
is
you know of the of the two biggest
kingdoms of of uh
of organisms the plants and the animals
have different schemes for growth
because plants are particularly
distinguished by having rigid cell walls
they have cellulose cell walls and that
means that if if you're growing and
you're a plant whatever's grown so far
has to be left the same and if you're
going to grow an extra branch that's
kind of a pure add-on you don't get to
kind of deform the thing that's already
grown so plants have this strategy
particularly the branching strategy sort
of everything about plants as you grow a
thing and then you go branches to that
thing whether it's roots whether it's
branches above ground whether it's
features of leaves all those kinds of
things it's all about you put you lay
down something and then you add
something on
for us animals
it's a little different because our cell
walls are are deformable and so we can
expect to have things where oh cells
grow and just puts more pressure and
these other cells are kind of squashed
up in some in some way and gradually
more cells get formed and so on and you
can you can have more diversity of
growth
because you have this possibility you
don't have to go it doesn't have to be
rigidly growable at every stage and we
have all sorts of different strategies
for growth but so for example one of the
things that uh happens for us is we have
skeletons and it's always a a um and
that they form the sort of framework on
which
you know the flesh is put on the bones
so to speak the bones define the overall
structure and then once kind of hanging
the muscles and everything else on those
on those bones so there's a question how
do the bones grow
and the typical thing
is that there are growth plates so for
example our long bones like in our legs
and so on they have growth plates at the
ends and those are the places where cell
division is happening and you're adding
more to the to the bones so the typical
kind of scheme is you've got this this
this long bone it just keeps getting
longer and longer and longer there's
always a mystery of things like the
skull which is something which has to be
sort of a closed container and it has to
stay a closed container how does it
manage to grow and the answer is it has
these separate plates and has these
suture lines between the plates and
things it grows at those suture lines
and gradually by the time you're like 40
years old or something everything has
solidified and um there's no but if
you're if you're um
for very young kids you can still that
there's still lots of stuff that's soft
and so on and it's still uh uh that
there's some uh i mean that's that's how
it succeeds in in growing even though in
the end it's it's a fully encased thing
but any case the so for for humans
there are these sort of particular
schemes of growth particular ways that
things grow like like for example when
we grow out capillaries uh in our
bloodstream small blood vessels the the
fundamental strategy there is actually
very much like what plants use that is
you grow a big blood vessel and you grow
little branches to that and then
branches to that and so on and
eventually what we what we have to do in
order to supply oxygen to all our
tissues is we have to have branched and
branched and branched enough times that
we're within two millionths of a meter
or something of every place in our body
there has to be some little thing that's
supplying blood to supply oxygen to to
make those tissues work
but but the um
so that's another scheme for growth and
another ones in our lungs the the little
um uh
um
um
[Music]
what are they called the the bronchioles
and then the alveoli um the the the the
whole tree of our lungs are like a like
a plant tree they branch about 23 times
i think um uh branching's progressively
smaller and smaller and smaller sub
branches and they grow out with big one
big branch then that sprouts smaller
branches and it keeps going a series of
branching times and different things go
in different ways i mean we have you
know i think another a trick that's used
um before we're born is you know we
start off with kind of
just sort of flipper paddle hands and
then the cells between the fingers die
off and that's how we end up with these
separated fingers that's another sort of
trick for growth but when you ask how
quickly
can can humans grow i think the limiting
factor will be the speed of cell
cell division and uh probably the dna
replication is probably
the the limiting step for that
and uh i think that's that will
determine the the maximum rate that
cells can grow that way i suspect that
you can get sort of a certain amount of
kind of rapid increase of mass
just by having uh more water picked up
by cells and so on and that that happens
the way to understand that when you have
a cell it's got this kind of gelatinous
stuff inside it that's mostly water and
the sort of a question of of how much
water how much of different kinds of
things get picked up into the cell and
that's a whole story of this thing
called osmotic pressure so the idea is
if you have
if you've got a cell
and uh let's see if i can can uh get
this right quickly if you have a cell
and it's basically got
a um
uh and and it has
okay so there's a uh and it's it's got
this sort of water with something
dissolved inside and then outside is
just plain water
there's a certain tendency for the the
things that are dissolved in the water
inside there's some probability they'll
escape to the outside and gradually it
will equalize the amount of of dissolved
stuff
cells fight against that by having
active transport of materials into and
out of the cell through pores and the
cell
cell membrane so a cell membrane around
the outside of a cell it's mostly this
thing called the lipid bilayer um and
that consists of particular molecules
that sort of cylindrical shaped
molecules roughly that align themselves
so that they have one end inside the
cell one and outside and i guess that
they're two two pieces of that but in in
the end the sort of surface of a cell is
mostly this kind of
almost crystalline type thing that is
this arrangement of of um of particular
lipid molecules that are long long
molecules but
in in the in the surface of the cell in
addition to this basic sort of bag
around the cell there are a large number
of specific pores that kind of are
drilled through the surface of the cell
that do things like transport materials
in and out of the cell
and and also do things like for example
there are things that will expose pieces
of of uh of rna that were in um
well they'll expose
uh basically that they're exposing
actually pieces of protein that are um
let's see how does this work this is uh
the the part of the way the immune
system works
is it says what are all the what are all
the things going on inside the cell
let's expose little broken down pieces
of that on the cell surface so that the
immune system can come and check that
this cell is okay so to speak and that's
yet another thing that's transported
from inside the cell to the cell surface
but there's also lots of pores
in the cell surface that transport for
example potassium and sodium into and
out of the cell
and that's something where there's
active control of those uh of the amount
of those things in the cell um and the
way what are those pores those pores are
proteins and in particular so protein is
this is made from specified from dna
and uh then but a protein consists of
this sequence of of units that are each
an amino acid that took about 20 amino
acids and so from the dna once
specifying okay this protein should be a
this you know a i don't know
almost all the lessons the alphabet are
used to specify amino acids so i don't
even have to know my amino acids to be
able to say this is a you know a b
a an x this or that or the other um all
in a sequence in this protein and the
backbone of the protein is always just a
sequence of amino acids but when a
protein uh when you you the protein once
you've made that kind of backbone the
protein then just sort of folds up
and so for example there will be pieces
of the protein where there are pieces of
the sort of sequence of amino acids
where those things always like to be on
the inside and there are other parts
where it always likes to be on the
outside and different proteins make very
different shapes like actin the protein
that's in our muscles is a long it's a
it's a triple helix i think um it's a
long stringy protein
or something like hemoglobin is a
protein that just has a little cage
structure um enough to fit one iron atom
to to transport oxygen in our blood but
different kinds of proteins have
different shapes
and there are two characteristic pieces
to protein shapes things called alpha
helices and beta sheets and alpha helix
is a is a sequence of amino acids that
will tend to make a kind of tube
structure and it's those alpha helices
that are used by the transmembrane
proteins that transport things like
potassium and sodium and so on into and
out of cells they make little tubes and
those tubes are controlled by other
parts of the protein and that's kind of
how you maintain active uh kind of uh
you actively maintain the concentration
of things inside the cell
when when cells replicate as i say what
what happens is the um the the lipid
bilayer membrane um
i'm trying to remember exactly how this
works uh how you go from one closed
sphere of cell to another one i think i
think i mean when you see things like
single-celled organisms they tend to
sort of pinch off and then the two
pieces break apart i think that's how
human cells do it as well not absolutely
certain and there's a question of sort
of how that happens how does it even
control the shape of the cell the answer
is there are little strings effectively
that are pulling that are deforming the
the um uh the shape of things and that's
um and those are
operating probably
uh actually don't know exactly how that
works
my guess is that it works by the same
kind of methods that a bunch of these
things work by which is literally a
little ratchet type thing where a a uh
one component is is literally sort of
walking one ratchet step after another
uh to move the to to move this string of
protein around but anyway so
so um i'm guessing that the um
there's an upper limit
on uh on how fast we can go there's some
organisms that grow pretty quickly i
mean some plants can grow pretty quickly
um and and so on one thing to mention
about humans
so one thing that determines our growth
rate i mean it's a pretty complicated
system but human growth hormone secreted
by the pituitary gland inside our brains
the pituitary gland
is a is a gland that is just happens to
be situated in the brain but it's mostly
secreting chemicals that are hormones
hormones are kind of the global
signaling chemicals used by biology to
determine sort of what happens in the
system one of those hormones is human
growth hormone and um that is the thing
that kind of signals this process of
of at least for for um
uh for humans after they're born signals
the process of okay add some stuff and
one of the things that's really weird is
that the pituitary gland doesn't just
release hormones continuously sort of
all the time
it tends to release them in sort of uh
in i'm not sure if it's actually in
pulses or whether it's
more at certain times of day but so that
means that this you know what you can
actually see i think people have
measured this in in kids when it's a
question of um you know how do your legs
grow and so on they actually grow a
discreet amount like every night they'll
grow a certain amount and that's induced
by secretion of human growth hormone
which then produces a cascade of
chemical processes that lead to cell
division etc etc etc so it's kind of a
weird thing that you would think growth
was always a very continuous thing but
actually because of the the control from
human growth hormone it uh it can be in
little little jumps so to speak
um anyway that's that's uh
that would be my
my thought about that
um
okay another biology question here you
are really uh uh challenging my my
knowledge of some of these things the
question
uh from great hair graced
um about the function of the human heart
is it best understood as a pump or a
different way
um well ultimately yes it's a it it you
know succeeds in pumping blood
um around the body the way that it it is
a it is a strange and very clever object
um that has
it's it's made a muscle
and um a uh kind of a different kind of
muscle than the muscle that is part of
our sort of conscious control
um parts of um uh our um
muscles that we we think to have to move
um heart muscle is it's it's a muscle it
has a pretty complicated morphological
structure it has a pretty complicated
structure of valves and and this and
that um and uh it um the
the pulses that the heart produces
are there are nerves venal nerves right
i think that are sort of in the in uh
that are part of the the the
non-conscious control of our brain
they're the sort of very fundamental
things in our brain
that produce electrical signals that
cause that kind of stimulate the heart
muscle and cause the heart to contract
um now once you've sort of it put in
that kind of that that electrical signal
the structure of the heart muscle is
such that you have this kind of wave of
contraction that goes around the heart
that causes it to beat in a certain way
and and that's that's good when it works
that way if you interrupt the the the
way that the heart is beating by giving
it some other electrical signal like if
you you know if you do the thing that
you absolutely shouldn't do
of uh you know one hand on one
uh you know plus electrical outlets
another minus
so you pass a current uh across
across your heart very bad thing to do
that that's why for people like me who
who are sort of um uh if ever i do any
kind of electrical thing i'm always like
put one hand in your pocket and use only
one hand and make that make that do
because that way at least you don't get
an electric current that goes uh goes
across your heart
um but in any case the the um
the thing that um happens if you can get
if the sort of other electrical signals
is that you can confuse the the kind of
usual contraction sequence of the heart
and it goes into this process called it
can go into this process called
fibrillation
where it's kind of just sort of randomly
uh contracting rather than doing its
systematic contraction that it does to
pump blood and that's that's a bad thing
and that's why uh there are these
defibrillators which are um intended to
give shocks to the heart that uh break
it out of this process of fibrillation
roughly what happens
is
uh in and this has been understood over
the last i know 30 years or so
that
in the the heart
has the way it's constructed it has a
sort of fundamental uh liking for
beating a dessert for periodically
beating just contract expand contract
expand that's what it's sort of that's
the attractor of what it wants to do
and if you just sort of poke it in more
or less the right way that's what it
will naturally do contracted span and so
on in the way that it's supposed to to
to operate correctly
but what happens is if you kind of kick
it out of that domain where it's doing
this kind of contract expand thing you
can get it into a different domain where
it's where it does not it's not on that
attractor it's kind of like
what's a good analogy of this um
let's imagine that we have some sort of
ball going around in a track and
normally it will just sort of go back
you know if you kick the ball out of the
track it will normally just sort of roll
back down the hill and go around the
track again but if you kick the ball far
enough away well maybe it'll go into
that other area in the middle where it's
sort of randomly uh moving around
and and for the heart the um there is
this so-called strange attractor this um
this other possible mode of motion which
is not effective in pumping uh blood
around and that's that's the
fibrillation process and the the usual
sort of the theory of defibrillators is
you give another electrical shock to the
heart
that uh if if the fibrillation started
with an electric chuck or if it started
some other way you're just giving it
it's an electric shock to sort of kick
it
back into this attractor this periodic
attractor that's it's correct expand
contract kind of uh kind of motion
so at least that's that's um
uh you know one thing it's it's worth
thinking about in the history of um
of science
when people were kind of wondering in
ancient greek times and so on how did
humans work and you know one thing
that's really obvious about us is we
think
and um uh and then people
were saying well where's the thinking
happening what's the machine what's the
what's the mechanism for thinking and
they look at humans and it's like well
there's a lot of stuff that's just
sitting there and then there's the heart
and just like as we think
you know we think about things and
things change and things are happening
all the time well the heart is something
where we can you know tell that it's
beating and so there was sort of an
immediate thing oh well if that's the
thing where there's change happening and
thinking is a place where there's sort
of change happening those two must be
related and so that was kind of a
scientific theory for a long time that
you know the heart was something to do
with thinking and it was only much later
that it became clear that you know
brains were really the the center of
that and it's something where it's um
sometimes it's hard to identify you know
when you look at
some piece of of us biologically and you
say what's the function of that piece
you know i'm i'm always amused by the
fact that when i learned biology when i
was a kid there were these parts of
biological cells where it was like the
golgi apparatus was uh you know in in
the textbook that i had it said it's a
part of a cell of unknown function
um well of course now we know it's it's
um all involved with protein synthesis
and so on but um there are these sort of
features of biology where people say we
don't know what it's for and sometimes
that produces tremendous confusion and
even sometimes uh terribly crazy medical
conclusions because it's like well you
can take that part out and it'll all be
okay um
just because we don't know what it's for
doesn't mean it's really not for any
purpose
um and uh you know we're um that there
are many many places where uh
in in the course of biological evolution
some things are the way they are because
that's the way they were you know we we
share
a lot of detailed uh biochemical
features and so on with organisms that
existed at least a billion maybe two
billion
years ago and they've been sort of
grandfathered forward
for what is it um now uh must be um you
know many billions of generations so to
speak since those species and we've
still got the same stuff and some of
those things are like well that wasn't a
very good idea but it works well enough
that we can still keep going with it and
if you say well why is it that way the
answer is it is that way because that's
the way it got chosen sort of randomly a
billion years ago and we've still got
the results of that a famous example of
that is in our eyes
the um uh the the eye of the type that
we have um has been uh sort of invented
in evolution maybe three four five times
um but in our invention and like the the
king crabs and things like that have
eyes like ours but they came from a
different evolutionary path
but for us
the one of the things that sort of a
piece of bad design as light goes into
the eye eventually it's going to be uh
it's going to
hit cells on the retina which are going
to turn it into electrical signals but a
bunch of the cross connections about of
retinal cells are in front of the retina
so it's like that's bad design if you're
going to have better optical properties
one would think you have those cross
connections behind the cells that are
taking in the light
um but
presumably it's bad design maybe it's
quotes designed that way through the
course of biological evolution it's been
selected to be that way because there's
actually a good reason to do it that way
but we just don't know what it is yet um
but there are many of those those types
of things
all right let's see
oh boy another medical type question
humans exposed to prolonged microgravity
suffer from well-known health issues
uh short of one
g of gravity do we know the minimum
gravity required to prevent such issues
i don't think we know that how would we
know that
so
first point to make
on the earth
there's gravity things fall
the
amount of gravity on the earth is
measured by the acceleration due to
gravity about 9.8 meters per second per
second
if we are on
the moon for example the gravity is
one-sixth the gravity on the earth
if we're on mars it is i don't know it's
somewhere between
maybe it's 50 60 i'm not sure it's some
uh something a bit smaller than the
earth
if we're in space
in in orbit for example and we're not
firing any rocket engines or anything we
will be weightless
because kind of everything is falling at
the same rate
um and that means that we effectively
have zero gravity
uh
now so when astronauts go and spend you
know six months a year whatever on the
space station they are in microgravity
most of that time and it's called
microgravity because there is usually
because of small acceleration forces
associated with things like the fact
that the earth is not a perfect sphere
and things to do with the slowing down
speeding up those kinds of things
there's a
uh
it's but for all practical purposes it's
zero gravity
and so that means things don't fall any
particular direction you put something
you know you put a blob of water in the
middle of the the space station it'll
just sit there and make a big big
spherical blob typically um it won't
fall in any particular direction
so
the question is what happens to us
humans under those circumstances and the
answer is it's not totally good because
there are all kinds of things like our
bones and so on we maintain our muscle
strength because we're we're actually
walking around in gravity uh we maintain
kind of the um uh the mineralization of
our bones because there's actually
pressure on our bones and things like
this um all these kinds of things we
were built by evolution in a sense to
operate in 1g gravity on the surface of
the earth
and uh so anytime we go into a different
kind of gravity situation um it's you
know we weren't we weren't designed for
that it's outside of the design
parameters of the human so to speak so
typically astronauts will do all kinds
of exercises to try and maintain
uh muscle mass and bone density and
things like this
what how would you make if you're going
to send people off for a really long
time
in space
where uh where it's where they're
weightless um what you can do
is you can sort of create artificial
gravity by having a centrifuge so for
example if you
you if you for example take some um
i don't know a glass of water or
something not a glass some some other
thing containing water you put it on a
string and you kind of whirl it around
you may know a bucket that's a better
better thing to do it with has a handle
as well um and you kind of whirl it
around what you'll find is that the the
um the water in the bucket um even if
it's so long as it's going round at a
certain speed it will be the the um the
water will have a force that is pulling
it to the outside of the circle um and
so it won't just even when the bucket is
upside down
um in that part of the circle the water
will stay in the bucket
of course that's that's some and so that
the reason for that is that the
acceleration
the bucket has to be accelerating
because in order to keep it going around
in that circle the only way it could not
be accelerating is if it was just going
straight in a straight line to keep it
going in the circle you have to
continuously accelerate the bucket to
keep it changing its direction of motion
so that it stays in that circle and that
means that that you are one of the
fundamental facts is that
acceleration is equivalent to gravity
that in fact you can't even tell that's
the so-called principle of equivalence
that albert einstein started talking
about around 1915
um that
is this idea that if you're in a
completely closed box
and somebody and it's it's on the
surface of the earth you feel gravity in
that box but you could also take that
completely closed box and you could
accelerate it at 9.8 meters per second
per second and it would be as if
you would you would not be able to tell
the difference between the force
associated with that and the force
associated with gravity by the way in
our sort of theory of of
of physics um we can kind of understand
how that all works that's a let me put
that aside for a second but um
so you can
have sort of simulated gravity by virtue
of acceleration and in particular you
can have it by virtue of circular
acceleration that will keep things going
in a circle
so the result is that you can make
artificial gravity by having a
centrifuge where for example sort of
everybody if you have a space spaceship
where the thing is just rotating around
at a certain speed then people can just
kind of uh
if you're just sort of walking around on
the exterior on on you know the inside
of that sort of circle that's going
around if it's going around fast enough
then
you will be feeling gravity just like
gravity on the earth
um
and so that's kind of the mechanism and
when people like in the famous movie
2001 a space odyssey that came out 50
something years ago now the the main the
big spaceship that's going to jupiter in
that movie um it uh it has a kind of a
its main part has a sort of a centrifuge
motion and then people just sort of
walking around it um like they would on
on the surface of the earth
um and
so that's kind of the way that you
achieve artificial gravity in in a
spacecraft now the question is how much
artificial gravity do you need i don't
think anybody knows the answer to that
people have tried growing all kinds of
things they try growing plants
sometimes some some kinds of things
manage to grow in a sensible way without
gravity other kinds of things get
utterly confused by not having gravity
um and as i say there are issues for
humans not having gravity uh my i i
think
i think it's a difficult experiment to
do because until one has a spacecraft
that has some kind of continuous gravity
centrifuge type thing it's kind of hard
to know uh what's going to happen if
somebody's there for a month or
something um in in some reduced uh
amount of gravity because one just can't
do the experiment
i think that um
uh
in uh you know this is one of the issues
if uh we go and make a mars colony or
something um it's uh living in
microgravity with not microgravity and
reduced gravity of mars um definitely
different things would happen um you
know given the other
you can kind of work out
if all else was equal you know how would
a child who who grows up on mars um you
know what would their uh would they be a
lot taller than a child on earth
um would they be uh you know what what
characteristics would they have you know
we weren't designed for that so to speak
so i don't think we really know
um but uh so that that's you know that
that's one of these challenges
um
let's see is question here from
uh okay there's a question from mikhail
about
can a quantum computer solve the protein
folding problem okay let me explain an
issue so i i talked about proteins a
protein
is this sequence of amino acid units
and some of them are quite short but
some of them might be um
uh
up to maybe a million
units long of this protein and the
question is you've got this long string
of of amino acids and each one of those
is a clump of i don't know a few tens of
atoms and the question is what will
happen to this big string if you put it
in water for example is this big string
going to just be a big string or is it
going to all curl up and make a single
blob
so the question of what it actually does
is a difficult question there are forces
that act between these different amino
acids these different uh
residues they're called these different
um
lumps of these different amino acid
units they have different forces between
them those forces are forces between
atoms and they're different kinds of
forces between atoms there are forces
for example in a water molecule h2o
the the the atoms the two hydrogens and
the oxygen are bound together by
covalent bonds what's happening there is
that there are essentially electrons in
common usually in an atom there's a
nucleus they're a bunch of electrons
that are outside the nucleus the nucleus
is pretty small compared to the atom
maybe a hundred thousand times smaller
than the actual atoms it's all
points in the middle but then but it has
an electric charge that keeps the
electrons uh attracts the electrons to
it and makes a kind of uh
essentially shells of electrons around
the nucleus
well if you put
atoms close enough to each other things
will happen so for example one of the
things that can happen
is what's called covalent bonding where
essentially electrons are being shared
between atoms and that process of
sharing electrons is it has the effect
of a force that keeps those atoms
together that's one kind of of chemical
bonding there's another big one is ionic
bonding where what will happen is an
atom will have
for example lost or gained an electron
and that will give it an electric charge
because then the charge on the nucleus
doesn't cancel the charge in the
electrons and then there'll be a force
electrical force of attraction and
that's what happens for example in
something like a a a salt crystal the
the um you know it's a sodium plus
chlorine minus and those things are
electrically attracted so it's a
different force of attraction there are
more uh sort of um uh smaller forces of
attraction between atoms
um one uh particular one is van der
waals forces
so the way those work
those are forces that happen it's a
little bit of a subtle thing
so
uh
let's see in in um okay a couple a
couple of things to say a little bit of
mathy stuff to say
the um the forces electrical forces
there is an inverse square law that is
the force between
two uh
two electrically charged things happens
to be the same formula for reasons that
we now have some good understanding of
at least in our physics project
it's um the force between uh
um actually doesn't it doesn't need all
of the apparatus so
that that's something you could sort of
understand in in existing physics um but
in any case the the force of attraction
between two electrically charged things
or repulsion between electrically
charged things
uh has a an inverse square
uh uh uh amount so if you know things
that distance r apart the force goes
down like one over r squared happens to
be the same uh formula as
force due to gravity except gravity is
always attractive whereas electrical
forces can be both attractive and and
and repulsive
okay so that's a one over r squared
force that's the electrical force
the um
uh the force
that um
uh well let's see there's a there's a a
um
a force when you
that there's another force which is
basically one over r to the sixth one
over r to the seventh
depending on various details
that's the so-called van der waals force
okay what is the origin of the van der
waals force
if you have
this is a little tricky if you have two
neutral atoms
uh atoms that have their electrons uh
and these shells around the nucleus and
so on
um there's a question will these two
neutral atoms
what what effect will they have what
will there be a force of attraction
between them or not how will that work
well
the thing that happens and it's a
phenomenon of quantum mechanics
is quantum mechanics
is
has this feature that well the
fundamental feature of quantum mechanics
is that whereas in classical mechanics
sort of definite things are always
happening things move in definite
trajectories in quantum mechanics
there's always a wide range of different
possible trajectories things can move in
in a sense they all happen but with
certain weights
that lead you to eventually say there's
a certain probability for this to happen
and the most likely thing for to to have
happen is the thing that is like
ordinary classical physics but they're
these little fluctuations um that are
around that classical uh case but
they're little fluctuations that are
different okay so that happens all over
the place at the level of quantum
mechanics and it happens in atoms and it
happens to the electrons that are in
atoms they're these little uh little
fluctuations in the shape of the
the electron shells and so on around the
atom and that
um
the uh
what happens is and that there's a way
to think about that in terms of what are
called vacuum fluctuations which are
essentially just a representation of
what's happening in in of this sort of
fluctuation process that happens always
in quantum mechanics but the end result
of this is the the electrons are kind of
getting jiggled around in each atom
okay so what happens is the electrons in
one atom get jiggled around that
produces a certain uh distortion of the
electric uh usually the atom is just a a
thing that has um uh it's just a
it has no electric charge but what can
happen is there's a little bit of
polarization of charge there's a the
plus charge with some fluctuation will
cause the plus charge to all go to the
top the minus charge will go for the bot
to the bottom that's just a fluctuation
it happens for a very short time maybe
uh uh you know a little more than a
trillionth of a second let's say you
just got this little fluctuation that's
causing the the uh the electric charge
to be separated in that way even though
the total electric charge is still zero
but there's just this fluctuation that
causes it to separate a little bit okay
so you've now got this other atom over
here and that other atom over there
it turns out that when you have an
electric dipole which is what this
separated electric charge
is
that electric dipole the the forces the
electrical forces produced by an
electric dipole will induce an electric
dipole in something else in which it is
possible to induce that so this other
atom over here also has an electron
cloud electron shells around it and this
dipole that has been temporarily formed
by a fluctuation in atom number one
is also
has uh that will induce a dipole in atom
number two
okay so so what well okay what happens
then is that you've got this one dipole
over here that's been the result of
fluctuation that induces a dipole over
here and then there's a force of
attraction between dipoles that happens
in a sense where the dipoles come from
they came from a fluctuation but the
force of attraction is always a force of
attraction whether the fluctuation is
this way or that way or the other way
it's always a force of attraction and so
that's what leads to these van der waals
forces that are a um a net force of
attraction between atoms
and that's that force of attraction is
usually one over r to the sixth
and um the you can actually work that
out in a little bit of a mathy thing um
the the the electrical effect electrical
force associated with a single charge is
one over r squared by the time you have
these two charges together a dipole it
has an electrical force of one over r
cubed and so what's happening is the one
over r cubed effect of the dipole is
affecting the other atom which then uh
then its dipole is having a one over r
cubed effect on the first atom and so
the result is a one over r to the sixth
uh kind of um uh force of attraction
between the atoms now it's a little bit
tricky it's it's but i said whatever six
or one overarching seventh it turns out
there's a relativistic effect that um it
happens because when you are producing
that this fluctuation is acting on this
other atom and then that other atom it's
the fluctuation produced in another atom
acts back on the first atom but the
point is the effect of the fluctuation
from one atom to another that effect can
only travel at the speed of light so
from one atom to the other the sort of
this okay i'm having this dipole
fluctuating in this direction okay the
signal the electrical signal that that
um is essentially it's not quite an
electromagnetic wave it's something like
that that propagates to the other atom
but that takes a certain time and the
the net result of all of that is that
you have a slightly different force law
between the atoms but that's that's a a
force that happens between neutral atoms
and that's one of the forces that
can have an effect there are also these
things called hydrogen bonds
which uh
work a little bit differently to do with
shared protons between
between uh
between molecules or between pieces of
molecules and so on but in any case i'm
just trying to explain that in addition
to the usual covalent bonding that kind
of
connects things like water
uh together that that's a very strong
force of things from shared electrons
and ionic bonding uh there are these
weaker forms of bonding that can also
happen and it's those weaker forms of
bonding that happen in this kind of long
string of amino acids when that cause
amino acids to kind of either want to be
together or not want to be together
there's also an effect of if they're in
a solvent like water there's also an
effect of does it want to have water
near it does it want to be hydrophilic
does it want to like water and have
water near it or does it want to be
hydrophobic and try and avoid having
water near it and that's another effect
that happens in proteins but the end
result is that this long stringy thing
will fold up in some particular form and
the question is what form does it fold
up into so in a first approximation it
will fold up into the form that
minimizes its energy so it will fold up
in a form where it's as tightly bound as
it can be where it's it's kind of like
as if if this if you think about this
thing the analogy of kind of a ball
rolling around in a landscape it will
tend to go to the lowest energy the the
kind of lowest place the lowest
potential energy placed in that
particular case and so similarly when
you're folding up a protein it will tend
to go to the configuration that has the
lowest possible energy
now two issues
one
can actually get to that lowest energy
state and two what is the lowest energy
state let's talk about can it get there
first
imagine you have well imagine you have a
bunch of coins on a table and you push
them all together they'll form a
hexagonal pattern they always do you
push them hard enough they'll always
form a hexagonal pattern do the same
thing with spheres
there is a configuration of spheres that
is the one that people use to sort of
arrange spherical fruit in grocery
stores and so on there is a closest
packing of fruit but if you of spheres
you just take a bunch of spheres and ram
them together they will not make that
closest packing they'll get stuck
they'll jam
so it's not obvious that just because
there's a force that just because there
is a best mineral energy configuration
most closely packed configuration it's
not obvious you'll get there just by
jiggling things around
so in fact in in proteins
it is not uncommon to have these
chaperone molecules that have the effect
of trying to help proteins to fold in
the right way to have this sort of
sequence of folding so that they'll
actually end up in the configuration you
want them to end up in and by the way
the the shapes of proteins are
absolutely critical to their function i
mean i was talking earlier about alpha
helices and proteins which are the
little tubes that can be used to make
sort of transmembrane transport of
materials into and out of cells that's
in order to make that little tube you've
got to have this protein this this long
string fold up in this helical pattern
to make this tube
and so the shapes of proteins are
critical and that's what
for example a lot of the way that we
operate is that proteins are a certain
shape and two proteins will fit together
like kind of a lock and key or they'll
fit into you know one will have a hole
and another one will fit into it and
that's a lot of how we operate
and uh for example drugs often target
particular shapes and proteins and
they'll stick something into that shape
or they'll they'll make some uh protein
uh have some some effect where it where
it uh uh is is
is stimulated by virtue of the thing
fitting together according to the shape
of the protein so the shapes of proteins
are a very critical thing to know it's
even hard to determine if you're just
given a protein it's like how can you
tell what shape this protein is you've
got a bunch of protein and it's in some
little you know vial in water or
something it's like you've got a bunch
of protein here what shape is it it's
hard to tell there are a couple of
methods
one is to make crystals out of the
protein and once you make a crystal all
those protein molecules have to be
aligned in some way and then you can use
x-ray crystallography to try and tease
out what the shape of the
of those aligned molecules actually is
it's usually it's a tricky business
because there are usually many shapes
consistent with the actual uh the x-ray
crystallography image that you get out
is something which is a kind of
transform of the underlying shapes of
the molecules and so for example that
the big thing that that um uh jim watson
and francis crick did in 1953 in the
sort of quotes discovery of dna it
wasn't a discovery of the dna molecule
that was that was well known what was
figured out was what um uh
what the actual shape of the dna
molecule was and a person called
rosalind franklin had done x-ray
crystallography on dna and she had
managed to get a sort of good x-ray
crystallography image is and the
question was given that x-ray
crystallography pattern what was the
actual shape of the molecule that
produced that pattern and what uh um uh
krikan watson figured out is oh if it's
a double helix then you get that pattern
but so it's it's often a bit of a puzzle
problem what the actual shape of
a protein molecule is and there are
other methods based on well nuclear
magnetic resonance or or what's
medically called mri but but for
the same technique it's called nuclear
magnetic resonance when it's when it's
used in chemistry and things um it's a
different the approaches to to finding
shapes that way but in any case back
back to um uh back to the question of
how the shape gets gets formed so it's
okay so the question is if you were just
presented with okay we've got this
protein um and it's got the sequence of
amino acids tell me what shape it's
gonna going to fold up into so the first
question is well what's the mineral
energy shape turns out that's a hard
problem to answer in general and why is
it a hard problem to answer well it's an
example of a problem that is just
computationally difficult to answer
so
uh let me try to give an example of that
um
it's
well
let's see the the
yeah his here's the the sort of the
classic
similar type of problem
is you're given a bunch of cities
around the world and you're asked to
find the shortest tour that visits all
those cities and clearly if you've got
ten cities
there are let's say ten factorial ten
times nine times eight et cetera et
cetera et cetera ways they're about
about um you know a little bit more than
a billion um possible
uh or
orders of those cities in which you can
visit them so one way to find out what's
the shortest tour you can make between
those cities is just say let me let me
just enumerate all billion cases and
just see how long each one is and work
out what the shortest of those is
well
that turns out obviously that takes uh
you know you have to go through a
billion possibilities and if you
increase the number of cities make it 20
cities instead of 10 then you're talking
about uh huge quadrillions of numbers of
possibilities it increases very rapidly
so you want an algorithm a procedure for
figuring out what's the fastest tour
what's the shortest tour
that doesn't involve just enumerating
all the tours so the question is can you
find such an algorithm and the problem
is there are it it seems to be the case
that there are many kinds of problems
where you simply can't find really fast
algorithms for solving those problems
so the sort of the general problem of of
kind of how do you arrange things in a
minimum energy configuration given
certain rules for how different pieces
can interact that general problem is the
the buzz word is np complete um the
uh that general problem can be
such that at least so far as we can tell
there is no way to solve that problem
with an algorithm that doesn't increase
where it doesn't take lots and lots of
computer time particularly as you make
the uh the protein let's say bigger and
bigger okay so that was the state of
things people for many years have been
like how are we going to figure out how
protein folding works because
it seems to you seem to have to try all
these possibilities or it you you
there isn't a fast way to figure out how
the proteins will fold
okay so gradually over time there's this
competition that's run every year for
who can best predict the folding of
proteins and they've been two basic
approaches to predicting the folding of
proteins one is the kind of physics
approach where you're saying let me just
look at this protein and let me just
imagine that i have a model of the
protein let me actually figure out how
it would move you start off with this
long string of protein in water and you
say how will it fold up what are the
physical forces that will cause the
protein to move this way or that way how
will it fold that's approach number one
it's kind of the first principles use
physics to see what will happen approach
number two is basically see what
happened before there are like thirty
thousand proteins in us maybe more um
maybe there are a hundred thousand
proteins where the structures are known
um you can just take those as samples
and you can say well look i've seen this
piece of protein and it i know
from this example that it folds up in
this or that way so i'm going to use
that to predict how this new protein
that i'm being shown is going to fold up
so that's kind of approach number two
it's kind of like same thing happened in
things like weather forecasting you can
either actually study the physics of the
atmosphere or you can just say well i've
seen a configuration of
of winds and low pressure zones and so
on that looked like this before so
that's the way i will infer what it's
going to do in in the second case so
there's been a long running competition
between kind of the um
uh the the the uh uh what um
um
sort of what what can be done with the
just follow the examples versus what can
be done with the pure physics
in recent times the just follow the
examples method seems to be winning
and in particular using modern machine
learning it's been possible to do pretty
well on predicting the structure of
proteins what's actually happening in
that case i was actually just uh
corresponding with a
friend of mine who's one of the people
who's been doing this particular
research
um saying why does it work
and i think the the basic answer is
because it turns out there are features
of proteins that we humans haven't
really ever noticed
but which are the large determiners of
the final shapes of the proteins but
which those are things which the machine
learning system has picked up so for
example in an alpha helix
it is known that certain sequences of
amino acids will always produce this
kind of helical structure
wherever they occur those are um
the uh you'll always get that helical
structure similarly certain kinds of
molecules certain kinds of amino acid
sequences will give you beta sheets
and and people have gradually sort of
classified this kind of periodic table
of different kinds of features that you
can identify in proteins that we can see
oh that's a such and such kind of
feature in the protein um but what seems
to have happened with these machine
learning systems is that they've
identified some more subtle
more complicated features
that um
that we humans had never really noticed
we didn't give names to them but they've
sort of noticed these features and
realized that those features can be used
to make good predictions about what the
shapes of the proteins will be
so in any case that's that's kind of the
um so what's happened is it seems like
uh
there's no there's no fundamental reason
why it should be possible to know what
shapes proteins fold up into but it
seems like proteins are sort of
repeating themselves and they're tending
to
to not do the arbitrarily difficult
computational problem they're tending
instead with the proteins at least the
ones that we look at tend to have these
these features that we can identify that
will tell us things about how the
folding works now an interesting
question is if you
um
the uh
if you um just pick a protein at random
what will it do and you know let's say
we have 30 000 proteins in us
do we have random proteins or are the
proteins that we have carefully crafted
to be proteins that are going to be good
for biology
okay so i've wondered about this
question for like 35 years and i've
asked many protein experts this question
if you take a random protein what will
it do how will it fold that's been a
very difficult question to answer and
some people say oh it's not going to
fold nicely the proteins that we have in
biology are ones that have been sort of
selected to fold nicely and other people
say you won't be able to tell the
difference
so i know from a number of years ago i i
just looked at all the proteins where we
do know their structures
and asked are the sequences of amino
acids apparently random or are there
regularities the answer is at that time
i couldn't find any regularities and
obviously these machine learning systems
have effectively found regularities in
the sequences which is what's allowing
them to make predictions about what uh
what the folding patterns will be
but the thing that um
the thing that was uh so this question
of you know you pick a random protein in
other words in the origin of life for
example could life have just had random
proteins and then life just discovered
oh this particular protein is good for
this and we'll arrange with this one and
so on and use that to build all the
things that we have in life or did life
kind of generate the shapes of proteins
that we have i don't think we know the
answer to this yet
um but in any case this question of of
if you're given a random protein what
will it do
and can we predict what shape it will be
we're getting
much better at predicting what shape it
will be i'm not sure how well we do yet
at a truly random protein that isn't one
that actually occurs in an actual
organism
or whether there's even any difference
whether whether it's just random protein
if you can do a protein an organism you
can do a protein at random i'm not sure
we know the answer to that yet
um but that's uh um
uh right
um
okay well
that was uh
we've been doing a very um
a lot of biology discussion here this
this this question about quantum
computers let me not get into the whole
story of quantum computers that's a
that's a long story about quantum
mechanics and uh i don't think
i don't think there will be anything
magic that happens with that um but uh
uh i think that the um
in terms of protein folding the
practical
problems that are being solved there are
being solved with these kind of machine
learning trickery so to speak more so
than a fundamentally different way of
doing computing
um
well let's see
uh
do i have one here that is um
um
quick um
other interesting questions but um
um
oh my
none of these are quick i'm afraid
uh
they're all fascinating
but um
um
not quick i think i think we have to um
uh
wrap up here and we've got a lot of a
lot of very interesting
questions okay there's one here maybe i
can do this
um
okay there's one from william here
is being able to get to the lowest
energy state that's talking about
molecules and proteins a statement that
there is a continuous series of energy
states the molecule has that the
transformations from one state to
another are smooth enough and that
there's no energy state that's isolated
from all others yeah okay so interesting
question
so this has to do with the whole general
problem of sort of optimization how do
you how do you get the best result from
something
so let me give you some examples so
let's say you're trying to find the
lowest point on a landscape
how do you do that you've got this
landscape let's say the landscape is
just a very
um it's a very
um it's it's it's a sort of smooth shape
and has a big hole and and you know it
has a peak and it has a big hole and so
on
one very straightforward strategy is to
start wherever you start on the
landscape and always keep following the
great gradient descent that means at
every given point you're at look at
which place you would have which
direction you would have to go to most
go down so the thing that is the
steepest descent the thing that is sort
of the the fastest down the mountain
from where you are
and if you follow that that dis gradient
descent that that steepest descent curve
for a sufficiently smooth shape that
will successfully lead you to the to the
minimum of that um uh of that landscape
but if the landscape has lots of sort of
craggy pieces and so on that won't work
you'll you'll follow that gradient
down and you'll just get stuck in this
kind of mountain lake or something it's
it's it's the local minimum but it's not
the global minimum it's not the river
down in the in the valley it's just that
mountain lake up on the side of the
mountain
so there's sort of a question of what
are these kind of landscapes like when
you have for example let's imagine
instead of being positions on a
landscape the positions correspond to
different configurations of a molecule
and which have and the height on the
landscape is the energy of that
configuration of molecule so the
question is as you move around on that
landscape you're like changing the
configuration of the molecule and is it
the case that you can do this same
gradient descent thing and just smoothly
go to the best to the minimum energy
configuration of the molecule or are you
going to get stuck where the molecule
has this shape and that's the local
minimum
and but you can't get out to the global
minimum so that's a sort of a
fundamental problem of these kinds of
things is what is that energy landscape
what is that kind of what is the uh what
does it look like and is it like a
craggy mountain or is it like something
very smooth where you can easily get to
the minimum by just following that that
steepest descent line
okay so in practice these things tend to
be quite mountainous we don't know how
mountainous i mean there's another case
which is it could be like um uh well i
don't uh like sort of the the idealized
golf course or something where it's all
flat but there's this little hole and
the goal is you know and and if if the
ball doesn't get right in the hole
it's like it's not going to know which
way to go there's no there's no kind of
a big bowl that's leading the ball
always to that hole
um instead it's it's like you have to
hit the hole or or it doesn't work
so you know what these energy landscapes
are like
is what determines how easy it is to
whether you can sort of incrementally
solve the problem um or whether you have
what kinds of techniques you use so one
one important technique that was
invented though in the 1980s there's a
technique called simulated kneeling so
the idea is if you are just always
following the down down down down down
the mountain path
then you'll get stuck in the mountain
late
but if you jiggle things a bit
then the chances are even if you got
stuck in that mountain lake that the
jiggling will cause you to jump out of
the mountain lake and kind of look
around for more ways down the mountain
so the reason it's called annealing is
because when a um if you have a metal
for example
the um
uh
if you
if you take the metal it's molten metal
and uh you let it cool down
it will there's a question of will the
atoms and the metal uh arrange
themselves in a nice perfect crystal or
will they arrange themselves in
different ways annealing is you heat the
thing up again to melt it again to make
to let the atoms rearrange themselves
and so that's that's kind of the idea is
you're kind of heating the system up so
that things are no longer just following
those gradient paths you're you're kind
of jiggling them around with the hopes
that you'll jiggle them out of those
local minima those local mountain lake
type things and get them to the global
minimum so that that's kind of the um uh
the the first question is what is the
energy landscape is it like a
mountainscape and then what kind of a
mountainscape and then it's uh can you
can you use something like simulated
annealing to get out of the local minima
and there's sort of a relationship
between the optimal annealing schedule
the optimal amount uh which you'd like
heat it up a bit let it
this is conceptually heating it up it's
not actually heating it up it's just
adding randomness to the paths that
you're following uh different amounts of
randomness and the amount of randomness
you add is probably somehow connected to
the kind of cragginess of the mountains
exactly how that relation
is is made is not super well understood
and and exactly what kind of mountain
shapes you get for different kinds of
problems is not well understood this is
a problem that shows up in machine
learning also because the problem of
training a neural network of saying i
want a neural net that's going to behave
in exactly this and this in this way
you have a similar kind of optimization
problem you're tweaking the parameters
of the neural net to get it to behave in
the way that you want and that's like
trying to find this sort of minimum in
the mountain um and uh by tweaking
parameters of the neural net and so all
these techniques like similar to
kneeling kinds of things are used in as
part of the process of doing training
for for neural nets
all right we better we better stop here
um
so thanks very much for lots of
interesting questions
and i think next week is uh us
thanksgiving and we won't be doing one
of these next week but um
i'll see you again the week after that
so thanks very much and bye for now